alors du coup nous on a pour mission
donc de faire du renseignement est donc
serein et me lasser le post vraiment on
s'est implanté quoi moi je fais les
écoutes depuis ici avec les deux
antennes boucle qui sont là au dessus du
véhicule avec star ici je vais permettre
d'écouter l'adversaire une fois qu'il
est mais avec ce soit ou qui vole qui a
un poste radio et on a encore un autre
moyen donc y ait en déporté avec mes
deux collègues et ils sont en mesure de
faire de localisation en plus on a pas
mal de choses sur des ongles
ici nous avons un système de radio
millimétriques donc ça nous permet de
capter les ongs n'y ait de l'écouté
ainsi que de les localiser les maîtres
de la dickens direction avec ce système
on ça nous permet d'estimer une position
du récepteur et demi donc cela on a on a
ça que constitué uniquement du système
pour partir en pédestre en isoler
pouvoir nous déporter et pouvoir faire
un tiers pour faire la localisation des
zones cno et menteur qui sont à placer
sur différentes positions à risque les
portes et il y en a un qui prend à sa
guise à sa grille pour tout nécessaire
tout ce qui est pour se couvrir et ce
qu'elle nous privait pour et est décédé
ça c'est des missions ponctuelles donc
là on est parti sur trois quatre heures
maximum et après si on part sur des
missions plus longues
ça devient sur le sac beaucoup plus loin
conséquence comme apprendre l'autonomie
au niveau des pâtés
[Musique]